[Music]
and feed
looking to take carter gets into the
center of the lane
hooks it in post the foul this is just
ridiculous
takes his time spins baseline over the
wrong
shoulder that is a difficult turn his
ability to show up to the gym every day
with a smile and ask a ton of questions
and
you know he complimented uh coach lucas
with just really taking him under his
wing and really helping him
bull's team should never be understated
our colleague bobby marks
called him the number four trade asset
in advance of the trading deadline out
on the market he is an
all-star for the first time in his
career the reserves to be announced
on tuesday the coaches from both
conferences
will be voting uh for the chicago
bulldog you see
zach levine with a great little
left-hand finish
chance for a two-for-one embiid euros
his way to the bucket
it's unfair if there's any doubt about
why people have this individual in a
conversation for the mvp
harris looking for help finds it in
embiid already 30 points 11 rebounds for
embiid
spins around three defenders again
to finish 45 seconds to go
mp step back jumper you
bet joel embiid
tying his career high with 49 points
how you make a case for the mvp a little
step back
for your 49th point of the game
let him know who's in the bill and big
fella